I I hadn't done a video on Andor why
because I hadn't watched and or why the
answer is simple because I saw Obi-Wan I
was so baffled when the numbers of Andor
viewership were coming in I guess they
were lower than expected and everyone's
like huh that's weird wonder why that is
well because those people saw the
Obi-Wan series and the reaction was
meh why would people get excited for the
next product if they didn't like the
previous product so I hadn't watched
Andor I have not watched any episodes of
the Mandalorian season three in fact the
thing of Star Wars that I'm most excited
about is pixel joker95's Trials of the
master also I'm going to talk about some
spoilers it's not as what is this video
I should title it something provocative
like so I finally watched Endor dot dot
dot
I might do that a little provocative I
won't lie it's a bit naughty it's all it
is to say I finally watched Andor it's
actually really good because what Andor
does well it does really well first and
foremost it looks really expensive I
feel like the budget was very well used
the CGI looked impressive the Practical
effects looked practical and not in that
practically throw the puppet in the air
kind of way I can't judge too harshly I
haven't seen the show I've seen that
I've seen scenes because things still
cross my path on this big verse known as
the internet and that looks stupid but
Andor had grit guts tone atmosphere I
will say when I was first watching it I
was like this is the least Star Wars
feeling Star Wars thing I think I've
ever seen I tend to like my Star Wars to
feel like conventional Star Wars but I'm
judging two very different molds here
that that's wishful thinking because
that Star Wars I'm talking about was
George Lucas's Star Wars when Disney
Star Wars tries to emulate George
Lucas's Star Wars it never lasts long
term they're my might be the short term
like oh hey feels like Star Wars but it
it fades it's like Andor knows that and
they're like okay rather than trying to
cheaply emulate Star Wars again and have
another piece of Disney Star Wars that
might feel like
Star Wars fan fiction long term let's
have our own Star Wars let's bring our
own grit our own vibe to the Star Wars
universe and have something that might
actually stand the test of time I
appreciate the guts for that that said
I'm telling you what I was watching I
was like this does not feel like Star
Wars cyberpunk 2077 maybe they dropped
the first couple I think it was the
first three episodes online all at once
I've seen a lot of shows do that I feel
like it's because
they're they're using a tactic it's it's
more the long game in a sense where they
won't necessarily grip the audience with
the first episode so they have to drop
three episodes to have the hook and for
me it was stellen Skarsgard when he came
on screen I was like this is the hook
and the whole scene I thought it was
really exciting glad to Stella Skarsgard
and I was like here we go and that
brings me to stellen Skarsgard and find
mon mothma working together that Dynamic
with them it was good stuff there's
something about stellen skarsgard's
character he's one of the more
compelling characters in recent Star
Wars that I can think of he has a couple
of great monologues that one where he's
talking about how he's
I'm going to paraphrase my God I'm going
to butcher it essentially saying he's
fighting for a sunrise that he'll never
live to see or something like that man
that hits also you see some Senate
scenes and there are these empty seats
in the Senate but it makes the world
feel lived and as does seeing everybody
do their day-to-day jobs you know their
mundane work in order for these worlds
to feel lived in you you have to have
that there's something about the small
talk the protocol and procedures that
come with a job that make you feel like
oh this is actually a job in this galaxy
and it works that you see the goings-on
and the logistics of the Rebellion
because you see that with the Empire as
well that's a thing that stands out with
Andor that I really liked is that they
made the Empire very scary they're scary
because they feel real it feels like a
fascist government that can just shoot
you in the middle of a crowded street
with impunity that's good [__] and it
hammers home the point that fascism like
that works in the way it works because
it's just it's being held together by
paper being held held together because
everyone's afraid because you've
demonstrated you will do that but
eventually people are going to be like
you know what death might be preferable
and you're just you're a stone throw
away from a civil war so in this really
dark Star Wars world of Andor you do
have that feeling of hope it doesn't
feel as Kumbaya light and hopeful as
I've seen other Star Wars be but it
feels like a realistic interpretation of
oh there was a point in this show where
I was like andor's doing like three
different things you know you have the
introduction you have the heist segment
you have the prison break segment felt
like they didn't know what they wanted
the Andor show to be so like ah screw it
we'll just do it all but it does come
together in a way that absolutely does
work for the prison break segment in
particular that prison kind of reminded
me of the prison in Face-Off did anyone
else get that Vibe it's like it was a
sister prison to the prison and Face-Off
anyhow they're just working tirelessly
on these things you don't really know
what these things are you just know that
they're things and they have this fear
system to keep people motivated to do it
and do it well and pump out a lot of
these things then there's a post-credit
scene where you see one of those things
they were making it's a rivet and it's
being built into something and it backs
up and it's like oh they're helping to
construct the Death Star they don't know
it also explains why they'll just take
large groups of these folks and like all
right prisoners
well they're they've gone to the island
that's fan service but it's fan service
with a purpose I appreciate that it's
not just like oh Death Star I remember
no it's like dead oh [__] that's why
they were killing them all it hits
heavier you don't see a lot of that in
Star Wars these days there were a couple
things in here that didn't really land
for me like it starts out and or's
looking for his sister well I guess
that's fine for getting the ball rolling
but then there's this enormous block of
Time episodes where it's just not on
your minds seemingly not on his mind and
then it was near the end he mentions it
he mentioned something about looking for
his sister and I was like
oh that's right that was a thing I had
forgotten almost like it didn't really
matter for the show maybe they're saving
it for season two but I I didn't care
also the main antagonist for a while in
here I do appreciate that they're like
all right there's low level Imperial
flashlight cop he's on a quest he's
gonna find this guy who killed a couple
people in an alley I was intrigued with
him for a bit and then at a point the
antagonist role kind of gets handed off
to this other Imperial who I found far
more interesting probably because she
ended up in a room with more hardcore
interesting Imperial types than this
low-level Imperial Security guy who
reminded me of Gabe from the office
became an Imperial Security guy it was
just kind of weird after that he's
stalking this lady he's showing up to
her work Uninvited and in the end he
just ends up eating a bowl of crunch
berries with his mom guess it has to
start somewhere imagine the whole
looking for and or thing like we know
him as Andor the Imperial didn't give
two shits at the beginning this so you
got to start it on the level someone
like him would probably be looking for
Andor then higher level folks will then
be looking for Andrew I just didn't feel
the exchanging of hands and the passing
of the role works so smoothly but those
things aside and or absolutely is one of
the better things that Disney Star Wars
has pumped out because it doesn't feel
pumped out it actually feels crafted so
I guess that's the wrong term but in a
world where a lot of Star Wars recently
has felt like Star Wars fanfic this was
definitely something that feels like it
was crafted with intent purpose and
passion and memorable for nothing else
isn't built on the coolest thing
happening is a cameo the Adam West
Batman would do that so stop doing that
[__] again can't judge too harshly
haven't watched it but everything I've
seen looks lame alright so Andor have
you seen it feel like the world has I'm
the last one
so now I've commented and let you know
what I thought but that Blasphemous two
trailer that was some good stuff right
see some people talking about how that
video did not show up in their feed
these are mad times we live in mad now
I'm just letting you know this Friday
the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
embargo is gonna lift your feet is going
to be flooded with reviews but I'm out
of town until next week so I won't have
mine out sorry about that is what it is
just letting you know but what did you
think of Andor whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]